denise benhamou merci d'être là merci ça
va donner ça va ça va ça va oui c'est
parce que je veux pas regarder l'heure
alors vous lisez l'avenir sur le sexe
des gens oui alors on fera pas de
démonstrations
non mais c'est incroyable c'est vrai
qu'on m'a écouté d'accord il faut être
pratique courante à écouter ça d'abord
ça a démarré parce que mes que les amis
quand j'étais jeune et c'est vrai on se
pose la question comment et le garçon et
puis après on descend plus bas dans le
pantalon voilà et qu'est ce qu'il a
comme sex l'avant-goût were moi qu'est
ce coup-ci voilà le côté basique d'abord
et puis petit à petit j'ai été dans un
club parce que j'apprenais le shiatsu
mais tu as peur parce que j'ai beaucoup
je dis que je suis taillé comme un
diamant j'ai cinquante deux facettes
d'accord fait beaucoup de choses et ça
se trouve on a en fait la voyance chez
millenium avant tout et la voyance sur
le sexe est venue au club
comment ça c'est quand vous voyez voyez
des choses dans les boules
boule de cristal alors je touche dans
wii mais c'est venu qu'après ces munich
après parce que je souffre et à des dons
de voyance à la base j'étais voilà voilà
c'est ça donc je regardais mais la
sexualité on a toujours branché et après
et donc je vais vous dire c'est venu je
sais pas comment c'est venu si je le
sais c'est venu comme ça moi c'est
instinct c'est que j'avais dit oui
d'instants oui monsieur mais oui alors
que ce alors c'est parce que j'étais
avec je vende le jpy la fosse avoir
avoué oui j'ai inventé un projet
d'épilation donc déjà ça m'a amené sur
le sexe bah oui normalement voilà donc
le sexe donc c'était facile
après j'ai fait guérisseuse alors comme
chez guérisseuse je masse depuis l'âge
de 13 ans quand tout s'est regroupé on
vous avait massé un zizi un jour donc
j'ai pilat j'ai pilé d'abord aidé donc
et vous avez vu entier qu'il est à cvg
pile depuis les années 80 d'avant garde
donc c'était tabou encore là bas c'était
pas les étiquettes et les cartes qu'ils
ont c'est plutôt des dons de voyance est
viré mieux vicieux alors nommé denis
sans rigoler maintenant on parlait
sérieusement c'est à dire tout cas on
arrive chez vous on peut voir une vidéo
mse des médicaments comment on fait
quand même un creuset commencé mais
parce que j'ai moins sépare feeling
g
il y avait un journaliste je trouver des
sujets et je trouvais que les la voyance
sur le sexe ça compte tout le monde ça
leur plaît à tout le monde et j'étais
sûr qu'il allait marcher
alors on va voir comment procéder
commerce d'abord brossé des données
gérées gagner un dixième juste pour vous
dire
enora on t'a reconnu 1 il souhaite
pouvoir mieux lire sur les testicules de
juliano notre patient est en condition
au bout de quelques minutes
denise une nouvelle vision de notre
giuliano
[Musique]
on avait le mouvement de pénétration
pour bouger pour faire sortir les
énergies voilà et tu penses toujours à
ton sexe
[Musique]
rouge à bouger
est ce que tu peux te tourner maintenant
voilà je me fais me familiarise avec son
son corps son set ton travail te
perturbe en ce moment beaucoup c'est
pour ça que la sexualité te perturbe pas
ce que tu as besoin de sexe et on
travaille en ce moment c'est pas fameux
faible du cher et il a trouvé du travail
dans les mains absolument mais hélas en
coupe à lommel et son orgueil
alors juste pour savoir denise de nice
donc vous y aider vous pouvez voir des
femmes en toute chose c'est vrai oui
mais voilà je rentre dans là c'est
pourquoi il faut un joli vicieuse
pourquoi vous partiez je rentre dans la
sexualité des légendes d'accord